welcome to week four of my accommodator
startup school this is going to be a
great session we have Gary tan who is my
good friend former partner at Y
Combinator the founder of Posterous the
founder of initialized capital which is
what he's doing now and an amazing
designer who's going to talk about about
product design and and how to make that
an advantage as you're building
something people want
and then following Gary we have cat man
yeah like who who is my current partner
at YC and Craig cannon to talk about how
you can use public relations and and
content to acquire users to to improve
the prospects of your company before we
get going I want to just mention a few
rapid administrative matters if you miss
an update I know everyone's trying to
get their updates in so that they can
meet the graduation criteria do not fear
for now the easiest thing to do is to
send your update in an email to startup
school at Y Combinator comm it's okay
don't panic
secondly we have as many of you know
just done a merge of a number of your
groups hopefully it goes incredibly
smoothly for everyone certainly it won't
and if for example there's a problem
with your group if there's no moderator
please let us know as soon as you can
again to start up school at Y Combinator
calm that's the easiest way to do that
if for some reason you think you're in
the wrong group it doesn't work for some
reason let us know and we'll accommodate
you to the best extent that we can if
you haven't launched we recommend that
you launch if you at all can that sounds
if that sounds like a broken record it
should and with that let's get going I
will I am hugely pleased to introduce
Gary tan thanks
thank you guys for coming all the way
out and spending time with me to hear
about design and well you know frankly
design can be incredibly complicated and
there's a lot to it but you know in
hopefully an hour possibly a little bit
longer we're gonna get through about a
hundred slides so I tried to cram down
basically everything that I knew that
founders would get wrong or you know run
into problems with all the time and so
it's not going to be super in-depth it's
think of this is more these are the
terms that you need to know these are
the basic concepts you need to know and
you know personally I am actually
self-taught and so you know the first
thing that I really wanted to start off
with is actually I mean it's almost
cliche to associate Steve Jobs with
design but I think that this is one of
the most important things if you're in
this room or watching on on the Internet
you probably already understand this
this is why you're starting a start-up
it's that everything around you that you
call life was made up by people that
were no smarter than you and you can
change it you can influence it and you
can build your own things that other
people can use and Steve says once you
learn that you'll never be the same
again and so the thing I really want to
underscore here is what is design it's
about making and building these things
that other people can use and if you
remove one word from that sentence it
actually doesn't work and so what we're
gonna explore today is you know well
what is design why does it matter we're
gonna go deep on both the concepts
around product design interaction design
and visual design but we're also gonna
see tactically how do you actually do it
yourself if even if you have no design
background whatsoever if you're a human
being if you're smart
if you can put yourselves in the shoes
of other people well you too can do it
yourself and in fact as founders you
probably need to and then finally we're
going to walk through well you know when
should you hire and how should you do it
you know when should you use a
consulting firm things like that
practical matters so I spent my 10,000
hours you know in actually I was trained
as an engineer so I've never been to
school for being a designer but I taught
myself you know whether it's books
learned by doing
I just always found myself not just in
my code editor but also in Photoshop
trying to dream up trying to figure out
what should it look like how do I want
people to feel what should I be building
before I actually put it to code so I've
been a program manager I was employing
number 10 at Palantir and then YC funded
me back in 2008 with a company called
Posterous which we will actually use as
an example for some of how I've thought
about product in the past and how you
might be able to apply that to your
startup in the future and finally I
spent you know 10 batches working with
companies initially actually just as
designer and residents so I sat here in
this room doing office hours with more
than a thousand founders just like you
just starting out how do I build my
first homepage what's my first time
experience and then after that what do I
do next
how do I build a design process a
product process and so what you're about
to see is basically the distilling of
those 10,000 hours one of the things
that I am most excited about the you
know when it comes to design is this
ability to actually you know sort of put
together the iconography of something
that is very significant and so you know
when I joined talent here's just 10
people and we got to design this logo
and one of the my favorite things about
it is this mix of both meaning and
aesthetics and so on the face of it
you know one of the things I really
wanted to do was sort of really
underscore what Palantir was about and
so you know at one level this word mark
but with this specific logo is actually
a Palantir it's actually an orb on a
pedestal from Lord of the Rings it let
you see into your enemy's secrets so on
a very literal level it made sense but a
more subtle level of this that was very
important to us as we were building that
company was that this is also a human
reading a book and so one of the major
themes of Palantir broadly is that you
know we're at this moment in society
where computers are able to help us
understand the world around us in a much
more fundamental way and so what I can
you know what a computer is is basically
the infinite book and so that was just
one example of where I've seen you know
design actually will help put together a
culture for a company and it's fun it's
just fun to be able to translate you
know all of these different pieces of a
company and why we're here what it's
about into something that can you know
go on a t-shirt or on hat and I had
actually and so really really big
disclaimer I'm an engineer by training
I've never went to school I'd you know
never went to school formally for this
stuff totally self-taught you know I was
a founder so I applied this just like
you I did it myself and now I'm a VC
basically by accident and so the things
that I'm talking about today will be a
hyper simplification you know if we
wanted to we could turn this into easily
a 10-week course just about each given
section but instead what I want this to
be is a road map so you might hear these
terms you know there will be times in
your startup like perhaps now perhaps
tomorrow that you'll want to actually
start applying these things you know
Google's your friend like there's
everything in the world that you need to
know it's out there and so
you know the computer is truly the
bicycle for the mind and so the other
thing that I really want to underscore
is you know we talk about design as the
singular thing on its own but it truly
is deeply integrated in this broader
picture of you know how do you create
great products it's not just design on
its own it's how design actually
interfaces with all the other pieces of
the pie so you know it takes great
product management you know in addition
to that great design and engineering and
customer support it's all of these
things and especially at your stage you
know don't box yourself in you know you
have to know that you are the the
Shepherd of your product and you're
going to have to do every single one of
these things so what is design why does
it matter in a nutshell it really is
just these two very simple things to me
it's a it's just creating things for
users that work well and delight them
and those are two sometimes disparate
things that will as well as we'll see
you know some of the most inspiring
companies to me in the world you know
they have design as a very core piece of
what they do and so you know you can't
talk about design without talking about
Steve Jobs and Apple obviously but the
first misconception that is probably the
most common misconception is that design
is how it looks
it truly is not merely how it looks it
is actually also how it works and that's
why in the slides that we you know that
are coming up we're gonna talk a lot
about that process on how it works you
know what should it do and you know what
are the problems I like to think about
like and you know I just got my first
like a camera and I kind of can't
believe I waited this long I love to
finally get one but you know one of the
really interesting things about Leica as
a brand it truly is this beautiful
design this incredible brand but then it
is also fun functional it's also about
the your deeply the functionality what
you know why is this thing better than
all the other things that existed before
it
so you know a review from 1929 actually
just straight-up told you that you know
a Leica at that time was basically
magical it was you know eight times
lighter and you know ten times cheaper
it was an incredible machine for its
time and it's still a pretty amazing
machine to other physical products as
well one of the great design
inspirations for me and for a lot of
other people out there is actually DD
roms who built all of these very simple
incredibly beautiful products that were
incredibly usable and one of the most
important things that I think that he
really showed us in his designs is that
good design is actually as little design
as possible so minimalism and so that's
you know a point that will return to
several times in this presentation but
you know the key thing here is how do
you create things that are not burdened
with non-essentials you know it really
is about purity about simplicity and you
know just to drive at home I mean this
is a guiding sort of force and sort of
everything that you know we see in the
marketplace today it's you know history
doesn't repeat it rhymes and you know
another theme that we'll get back to in
this talk is actually simply the fact
that there's very little and totally new
Under the Sun in fact as designers you
probably shouldn't be spending too much
time trying to be extremely novel
because novelty is the opposite of
functionality and so what do I mean by
that earlier we talked about form versus
function in the form of delight and
works well these were sort of the two
yin and yang the opposing forces when
you're trying to put together a design
you know we obviously always want
something to be beautiful want something
to make you feel good make the user feel
good but at the same time you know and
delight is also a part of novelty it's
that hey this is new I've never seen
this before this is interesting you know
I want to see more of this like let me
turn the page let me click next but at
the same time function is the thing that
you
that's the steak that's you know if if
delight is the sizzle and works well as
a steak that's why we're here we're
trying to get something done and so you
know part of the problem with you know
form over function and this actually
happens even in the best products I mean
I'd like to call out Apple for it's not
I mean that is you know the definition
of form over function I mean this is a
photo from their marketing website and
certainly it's incredibly novel
certainly it serves the purpose of a
marketer to be able to have this very
novel different thing and differentiate
it from you know all of these other
smartphones out there but in terms of
function when I'm watching a video this
is categorically worse like why am i you
know I'm not here for the knotch I'm
here for the content and this happens
all over the place you might go to a
restaurant later tonight and it's a
beautiful restaurant incredibly well
decorated a very very thoughtful
incredible food but you'll walk in and
you'll sit down at this seat and gosh
it's so romantic but I really can't read
my menu I can't even order like I you
know this is again an example of form
this idea you know well we want to make
people feel like this is a romantic
premium incredible experience but then
if I can't even read the menu why am I
here
and so and this happens all the time I
mean you know they're one of my favorite
books that I highly recommend that you
read is a Don Norma's design of everyday
things and he basically has a whole
chapter about this on doors that are
incredibly beautiful but you have no
idea how to use them and so this is you
know one of the more absurd situations
of like someone actually had a right
pull on this thing because too many
people were just could not figure out
how to use a door a door is one of the
simplest things that you could possibly
try to use but you know when you put
form over function if you put the wrong
door or you know it's too elegant
there's not it's not clear how you use
it well that's you know missing the
point and so if you take a moment and
try to think through like why is it that
we see you know
over function so much in you know the
things we use the products we use just
walking around in our daily lives you
know why does this happen you know
clearly this should not happen and so
that form should follow function and
deep down I really want to emphasize the
one thing that frankly as founders I
think you need to spend a lot of time on
and that's empathy this is the thing
that I admire you know one of the things
that I admired the most about my time
both working at YC but also as a founder
going through Y Combinator back in 2008
it was that sitting down with Paul
Graham he would give us such incredible
advice about specifically how what are
your users thinking you know what are
they feeling what why are they here
and really being able to peel away the
layers of like you know I know we're
sitting in a room looking at this
particular UI but you know put yourself
in the shoes of someone who has never
seen this before
and this is something we'll come back to
again and again you know and you know
one of the things that I put actually in
you know my recommendations for design
resources and on its face it's kind of
absurd this is this depression-era book
written by Dale Carnegie a self-help
book but I actually think that it should
basically be required reading for
founders it's that you know one must
actually become genuinely interested in
other people you actually have to see
their point of view you you don't want
to be able to be sympathetic like
understand what are their ideas what do
they understand and you know what do
they actually want and you know this
goes back to YC itself the first day you
get into I see you get a t-shirt that
says you know make something people want
and I think I don't know if they still
do this but do they do you still get a
t-shirt if you get an exit that says I
made something people want yes I need to
get mine by the way oh shoot okay maybe
that's why I haven't gotten mine yet oh
so one of the things that's really
interesting about building highly
technological products is that we often
think about them is incredibly
complicated you know machinery but the
most useful mental model for me in what
I've been doing is actually that you
know to not think of it as you know
building a car or even building a
website or you know writing software or
anything like that it's actually about
throwing the best possible party you
possibly can and so if you think about
great parties you've been to there's no
line
you're ushered right in a human being
some ideally someone you know someone
who's very friendly comes to you and
says hey welcome I am so glad you're
here here are your friends oh let me
take your coat
you know beers are over here and so you
know that sort of politeness that
inviting welcomed nature that
thoughtfulness that's something that you
really have to keep in mind as you do
you know your work as not just a
designer but as a founder and the key
piece here is actually knowing what
problem you're actually solving just
being very crystal clear and you know
this is sort of if I'm you know starting
to sound like a you know sort of if I'm
repeating myself I mean that that in a
nutshell is I think what you're going to
get over and over again at startup
school is that really how do how do we
be as crisp as possible about here's the
problem in you know that we need to
solve and this is sort of the core tenet
of design thinking as well and so part
of the problem with not knowing what
your problem is and in going back to
lack of empathy and going back to you
know basically form over function is
that if you don't know who that user is
what their problem is then you are in
danger of creating something like this
so if you you know to basically each of
these do sort of talk about a particular
price you know they refer to a
particular problem that someone might
have but if you buy any of these
products and you have that problem
you're trying to solve now you have two
problems if anything each one of these
you know each one
these inventions were created mainly to
serve the central problem of their the
inventor of the inventor wanting
something to solve and so you know this
is the opposite again like you know just
to give more examples this is the
opposite of empathy this is something
this is you putting novelty putting you
know one's own interests ahead of your
users of society of you know the people
around you and so at the end of the day
if there's no problem then there's no
solution it ends up being designed for
its own sake and you know design for its
own sake isn't design its art you know
and there's nothing wrong with art I
love art but you know that's not what we
here for actually it's you know founders
creating things that people don't
actually need or you know engineers do
this too we you know make stuff that we
think we need and then actually it's not
something you know it's not better it's
not novel it's not something that other
people actually want and that's a
problem so there are so many types of
design you know it's no mistake that
some of the most obvious examples of
companies that are designed driven there
are actually hardware companies there
are as many kinds of design as you know
types of things that humans need it's no
mistake by that you know architecture is
absolutely a form of design branding and
identity you know communication design
being able to communicate something
using data and iconography or Maps or
charts furniture design you know a piece
of furniture easily has all of the
Meccan all the same mechanisms as
anything else that a human being might
use a landscape design how does someone
go into a place how do they use it where
you know where do they know where to go
you know packaging so how does this make
me feel when this arrives with my
doorstep if this is a gift you know why
is there a gift box anyway and you know
what you know what is the form and
function of each piece each piece of
this physical object or you know
transportation design like a car is one
of the most evocative things it's you're
almost entirely pure emotion but for the
people in this room you know I think
that these are probably the ones that
most relevant to you and we're gonna
spend a bunch of time talking about that
and so this is again an extreme
oversimplification but the way I would
break it down in terms of design for
startups really is product design so
what's the problem and who's it for
interaction design so you know how do we
actually do that right how do I actually
you know create wireframes create the
flows create the sort of intermediate
step between that and the you know pixel
perfect ready to go ready to implement
thing and the visual design actually
really is about that last mile and you
know part of the reason why we divide
this up this way you know to be frank
the ideal is that you have a co-founder
on your team who's able to do all of
these and then if they can code that's
amazing if they year they can do
business to you that's incredible all
right but that's obviously a unicorn
like you know unicorns are incredibly
rare they do exist though and I'm sure
there are a few unicorns in this room as
a matter of fact and if you know
certainly quite a few watching online so
you know shout out to the unicorns in
the room and so part of it is you will
find very specific people who have
experience and who are extremely good
usually at one of these things if you
can find someone who's good at a few of
them you're really really blessed and
you know man
if you can find someone who can do all
of those things immediately make them a
co-founder but only if you've known them
for a while so going back to the overall
product process I mean there is sort of
a sequential aspect to it truly you
start with product design you know in
each of these it really is a little bit
of a water flow sometimes you really
can't start interaction design without
actually capturing requirements and then
finally of course engineering you know
ideally you're kind of in conversation
all the way through but you know
engineering and actually implementation
often that is something that happens
afterwards so let's dig in a little bit
to product design and so
what's funny is I'm cheating a little
bit here so I am actually mashing
product management in to this but to me
I actually just can't do I can't do
product without I can't do the design
process without doing this part and so
it really is thinking about the business
case what's the problem who has the
problem what are all the possible ways
to solve the problem and what's the
actual priority for each of those parts
and so you know indulge me I know this
isn't exactly formally a part of design
I just don't know how you could possibly
do design without doing this part too
and you know every single one of these
things has a fairly specific deliverable
and so in this case you know the
deliverable here is a PR d-- a product
requirement document or you know you can
also call it a spec and so the
interesting thing is there's not really
one way to do product design just as
this you could call this product
management some Microsoft calls a
program management and then some
organizations you know sort of
de-emphasize some of this stuff and they
just call it project management but the
project manager still actually has to
think through all of these things so you
know the labels matter less the fact
that you do them matters a lot more and
so this is actually the the actual
content of my YC application from you
know basically January of 2008 or I
think it was February and so everything
that you know it you really do sort of
have to start with a problem statement
it's uh you know what we were trying to
solve is this ability to post online we
looked at online services at the time
you know blog platforms have been out
for a while but they're you know pretty
stale actually and the iPhone was brand
new and then we looked at email as sort
of this Universal way to get content
online and we thought this is a novel
different way to actually do it and so
one of the most valuable things that you
can do once you have that
the statement is actually to think
through who are these very very specific
people who have this problem and so I'm
gonna use Posterous an example to walk
you through personas and so personas are
just one tool for designers or product
people to think through who are these
very very specific people and it's just
a tool
you know there's not really one way to
do this either but this is what we did
you know we thought about our users
really is three different types David
the dad is sort of one of them you know
we kind of want to identify them as
human as you know specific human beings
like this is a very abridged version
that you might do you know sometimes you
fill them in on backstory like what
school did they go to or you know what
kind of family did they grow up in or
you know or very specific things like
you know what type of phone do they use
or what type of computer do they use did
you know back then it was did they use
Internet Explorer or did they use Chrome
did they use you know I'm not sure if
Safari was even out yet you know what
are they used for email you're what type
of technology what level of comfort with
technology do they have and so that will
actually help you a lot when you're
making decisions about well what are you
trying to do and you know what are the
what are the features that really matter
another persona we had was actually
David's family and so we you know
captured this in the form of grace the
grandma you know and some of this is
actually in tension as well she's a
little bit less she has it uses an a
sous netbook she uses hotmail she
doesn't really understand exactly how to
use it and part of the reason why this
is incredibly important is thinking
through different you know both modality
and level of comfort with technologies
often some of the most important things
like you know you guys some of you in
this room are actively thinking about
building things for totally late adopter
industries you know some of the best YC
companies in the past five years have
been you know they're being deployed to
construction to you know global freight
and so if you walk into any office in
the world
you know you're gonna find some
tech-savvy people but not a lot and so
you know even for you know enterprise
companies for b2b companies in the room
these personas it's still a very
valuable exercise because it makes it
very clear you know you might have your
decision maker you might have your
executive and then you might have your
in line level worker and there are
capabilities with you know their
motivations why they're here they might
be very different and finally we also
had you know this was the dawning of
social media is sort of the Cambrian era
of social networks and so it wasn't
clear that Twitter was going to win yet
there were sort of a dozen different
social networks that were happening and
so this was another persona she you know
she had very specific needs and so we
were trying to build something for her
as well and so one of the things you
really do have to do as you think
through a sprint you know whether it's
the next two weeks or the next month you
know the shorter the better frankly you
know a PRG document basically will
detail here are the actual features of
what we're trying to build and so
there's not really one way to do it you
just get them try to bucket them into
coherent features that make sense so in
our case you know one way to do it for
us would be post by email with plain
text that's just one coherent thing
that's a capability you know you can
hand this to an engineer and they would
understand what exactly that was and
then post by email without an account so
one of the things that we did for
Posterous that was very novel was that
we didn't have a signup flow on our home
page all you had to do was send an email
from whatever email client you actually
already had and you could attach
anything to it and we would just reply
with your new URL and what we that was
very intentional in that we wanted to
cement a totally new novel behavior that
nobody had ever done so you could just
email post at posture calm and we take
care of the rest the interesting thing
was that wasn't the the capability
itself was not novel there were other
people who were doing it but it wasn't a
central part of the flow
and so you know once your cape once
you're able to do bait the basics of it
you know there are other things that you
want to be able to do photo attachments
being able to take multiple attachments
and turn into a web gallery being able
to support videos and then finally a
security aspect that was very important
for us early on was that you know we
launched at TechCrunch
Michael Arrington himself actually
reviewed us and he immediately he knew
that if he started using it everyone
else in the valley at the time
definitely had his email address and so
he almost immediately tried to get his
technical friends to try and hack him
and luckily we had already figured that
one out so it wasn't possible for
someone to actually spoof his Posterous
email address and that was novel and you
know actually important for us and so I
want to pause there and actually say
earlier when I said it was these steps I
actually lied there's actually an
additional step in here this whole
exercise when you're talking about users
this is actually called user research so
if you see that term out there if you
you know end up trying to hire people
for that role this is sort of where it
fits it's that you know then frankly if
you're working on your startup you
should be you know just doing this as a
matter of course like you should not be
you know outsourcing this this is just a
basic piece of customer development
understanding your users spending time
with them you know being able to write
down specific personas for these are the
types of users we want to we want to use
our product and to be as basically crisp
as possible around you know what their
needs are you know that we call that
user research and this actually does
done right it does actually happen
before you even you know start thinking
about what problems solve at some level
so you know if some of you out there are
trying to figure out what problem to
solve sometimes you could just go and
talk to people who you want to build
software for and that has worked for
people that that will shake out their
problems
so once you actually know what these
requirements are the next step really is
prioritization and so this is just a
guideline this is just work for me in
the past there's not one way to do it
but you know this is more so basic
project management 101 but being able to
assign these priorities to the specific
features is actually a very very useful
and important exercise you know p0 is
pretty self-explanatory just start on
the this is just the core thing if we
don't do this then you know what are we
here for and so you know p1 is what you
would consider you know the next the
next obvious step you just wouldn't ship
without it but maybe it's not quite as
core and then you know if you think
about this in the terms of say a two
week or three weeks sprint you know you
try and get all the p0 bugs the p1 bugs
you know then actually sorry I skipped
ahead a little bit in that you know if
you haven't started using a bug database
in your software development you
absolutely should in fact that's one of
the key ways that you you know you as a
as a small team you might not need it
but as you grow your team it can be one
of the most fundamental ways that you
can make sure that you're doing the
right things as a product you know
especially as your team grows having a
bug database and assigning these
priorities and you know it doesn't have
to be this you as a team could you
figure out what these priorities mean
for you but being able to sort of manage
a given sprint just at the beginning by
putting these bugs in linking to a PRD
document or all of the you know the
wireframes or the visual comps that you
know an engineer needs that can be one
way coherently you can run your whole
product and engineering organization and
so you know as we go down one of the
things that has always worked for me is
actually you know a lot of the devil in
the details is actually in priority two
and three because things will always go
wrong almost guaranteed I mean I just
have never been through any sprint or
any release that you know they're just
things that are totally unforeseen that
break things and so part of the reason
why this priority prioritization is very
important is that it makes sure that you
try to set up realistic goals you know
one of the most dangerous things in
product development period is that if
you don't have these priorities you
don't know what to cut and so that
two-week sprint might become three weeks
four weeks six weeks you know two months
three months and then you never [ __ ]
right you know and so we'll talk about
that in a little bit but this is really
why priority matters and so in this case
you know it's pretty straightforward
post by email with plain text hey that's
must-haves we're just gonna start that
first and then one of the things that
you know you don't always write this in
the spec but it's something that's just
very useful as you think through this
stage of your product development
process it's really helpful to think
through who of my personas who of my
users need or want this and you know is
that important what's the interaction
between them you know post by email
without an account well some of our less
technical users are actually very scared
by signing up for new new products and
so being able to do this without an
account really opens up our user base to
the whole set of people who are not very
technically savvy and then Photo
attachments support David and Irene as
power users they both you know it's 2008
they you know they had the newest most
beautiful iPhone and so is immediately
the thing that they really really wanted
to do and you know p2u as you go down
you can kind of break down what is
important and what is less important so
you know to be frank this has never
happened before in my life but if you're
very very lucky and your product
development goes awesome in that
particular sprint that's often one thing
that you can just start you know it's
valuable to have p2 and p3 things as a
part of a given sprint simply because
sometimes you'll just have extra time
and someone will be able to get farther
along than you hoped and so the other
way to you know reason why it's useful
is that then you can think of
your product across different Sprint's
so you might be doing a release this
month and then p3 file video file
support at least you know if you're a
software engineer knows that that's
something that they want to do well when
they're factoring when they're actually
writing those classes or writing you
know writing the library or architecture
of that code they'll know that they
can't make it just for photos they'll
also be able to support other types of
media and that can actually save
everyone on the team a lot more rework
and so you know one of the key
difficulties of product is always trying
to figure out you know what are we doing
now and what are we doing later and so
priority and being able to be very crisp
about these requirements that's one of
the most fundamental ways that you can
make sure like release to release you
you know that the products going in the
right direction and so that's you know
really really product management 101 but
if you do this you will be far ahead of
pretty much you know a lot of your peers
a lot of pee a lot of people don't even
do this very basic step of writing down
what these features are who are they for
where the problems were trying to solve
and then what are the respective
priorities you know and one of the
classic reasons why you know we kind of
talked about this already but if you do
these the prioritization up front then
p.m. again product gets very easy
because you can just cut off the bottom
everyone sort of knows well you know
we're gonna start with P zeros first
then P ones and then oh if we're ahead
like let's do the P twos and the P 3s
but if we're late
well again the key thing that everyone
and all of you will run into this you
really have three things in front of you
scope quality and time so you know how
much you do that's the part of the
prioritization quality the reality of it
is this is not encompassed by your PRD
it's just purely in how people use your
product you know how many bugs are there
are there things in there that just
don't work and that you know that's sort
of always an issue and finally time you
can all
you know do all the features you want
with the highest possible quality but
you know you might have to slip your
date by two weeks three weeks four weeks
and you know if you don't cut scope
likewise well you might be able to hit
your time but you know users are going
to run into thousand bucks in production
and you're not gonna like that and so if
we work backwards from that then this is
precisely the process you use to sort of
fight that and so you know the other
thing that is very common there are the
reason why prioritization is incredibly
important is that you know without this
well you you basically can head off a
lot of really strange product decisions
at the pass and so if you ever get
incredibly frustrated with you know
you're deep in some settings panel in
you know your iPhone or something you
know any sort of product and you're like
why is it broken like that well it's
probably beeping it's probably because
someone failed to do this properly and
so they just said you know what eff it
we'll just ship it and so you know it's
a real danger like product quality and
products you know really really fail
simply because prioritization and these
basic requirements are not really
figured out and so finally you know and
the classic thing that you know personas
really help you with is sort of this
classic trade-off of you're gonna have
users who are incredibly savvy and some
people who are incredibly unsaved II and
how do you actually deal with that how
do you think through not just what
you're going to do but also how do you
represent it on the screen and so all of
these things are incredibly important
for this very first part which is just
pure product design so interaction
design so you know who the user is you
know what the problem is how do we
actually translate that into you know
something that you know you can actually
start working on and so the question is
you ask how will they actually do it
what are their goals you know and how do
they achieve it and so at the end of the
day what you're trying to get to is
either a prototype or a wireframe and so
what these things are are basically you
might use it a tool like OmniGraffle or
you know there's quite a few prototyping
wireframing tools that are out there and
what you want to do is figure out just
the text just the call to actions just
the flow screen the screen you don't
want to care you don't want to care
about color you want to care about you
know really how it looks what font you
use you don't even really have to worry
about layout too much though it is you
know I would start thinking about layout
you know as a part of this process and
so the most interesting important aspect
of interaction design is actually that
people treat you know then this is kind
of a very shocking thing to me I did
research at Stanford for the late
professor cliff Nass and he built an
entire career at Stanford based on this
notion that people treat computers like
people and you know it turns out that if
a computer is polite to you you know a
person will be likewise polite back or
you know being negative will sort of
elicit the same response almost every
psychological principle that
psychologists have proven cliff nasan
byron Reeves and BJ Fogg at Stanford
were able to show that people mirror
with computers even without any sort of
anthropomorphic assists without without
you know Clippy without you know an
avatar without anything like that truly
every interaction you have with
computers they're actually a
conversation as a conversation that
happens over and over and over again
because it's written in pixels is
written in design it's written in code
and so what is this about at the end a
day like you know interaction design is
actually about commands it's actually
about telling people what to do and you
actually doing it people are incredibly
suggestible actually one of the most
interesting psychological phenomenon
that I can think of it maybe explains
Trump and a lot of other things
actually when you absorb media whether
it's reading or you know any type of
media period you actually read that
stuff in your own voice and so that
actually becomes you know deeper that
you know kind of a part of you and so as
an interaction designer and interaction
designers not merely the person who
figures out where the buttons go or what
the layout might be or what the flow is
it's also they're also the writers they
actually are trying to influence people
directly by using direct command
language and so this is actually one of
the most common mistakes that founders
make they write like this and well you
know so just to put a point on this
really command language is about you
know people will do whatever you tell
them to do you just do really do have to
tell them and so you know this is a
super common thing in fact I'm pretty
sure you know a lot of you are making
this mistake in your home page copy and
your design and your first-time
experience you know it's passive voice
your your you know you're not showing
you're telling and you're just
describing something about what you're
doing and sort of this you know sort of
third party disembodied voice and I
thought a lot about why this is I
actually think big companies actually
can get away with this if you go to most
big company websites they are actually
written in a very passive voice you know
if you go to Microsoft's homepage and
start clicking through the products like
the product names are like blah blah
blah server Edition admin you know 2009
whatever it is like this insane word
salad and if you read it you have no
idea what that product is and who's it
for but Microsoft can do that because
it's incredibly big and it has a scale
that's unimaginable and it has a sales
force that will go out and sell their
product and they have incredible amounts
of capital but you as a start-up cannot
afford that and so everything that you
write needs to be direct it has to be a
direct personal voice and you need the
call to action be incredibly obvious
like you know the previous you know why
is that sigh why is this so small like
this happens all the time actually
people never are opinionated
about what you want the next user to do
and so you know this is an extreme
example obviously but you know what you
want is you know contrast you want to be
incredibly direct you want to use
command language and you want the call
to action be you know someone goes to
that webpage and they just know they go
to that mobile app and they just know
what they need to do so you know the
other part of interaction design that is
actually also very important is trying
to figure out how do you you know aside
from direct command language how do you
get people to actually do things and so
obviously this is an oversimplification
but I generally think about this in two
ways one is how do you remove actions
one of the things that Paul Graham
really directly you know called out to
me on our signup page back in 2008 was
why the hell do you have a confirm
password you know well I mean you have
their email address if they if it's
broken just ask them to you know click
forgot password it's fine
it's really not that bad to just have
them type a wrong password and have them
recover it and most people won't type
the wrong password so it's fine
why would you for this strange case that
doesn't happen that often and it's
actually really interesting if you
remove that confirmed password it
actually will increase conversion on a
signup flow by as much as 50 percent on
average so it's significant you know
cognitive load is an incredibly real
issue the other strategy that you can
really use is how do you chop up an
action if it's incredibly complicated
how do you break it up into steps and so
you know I like to use this example this
is Lego Windows 95 is this absurd you
know I mean one of the first Wizards
really to come out but you know I think
that there is an a timeless aspect to it
you know the other thing that I often
think about because you know some of you
in this room will be doing fairly b2b
enterprise you just like complicated
configuration steps you know kind of
like doing your taxes actually you don't
have to do the taxes that often but when
you do it can get really complicated you
got you know you might have branching
flow you might have a lot that you have
to take care of and so the other thing
that you can do is actually chop up
those acts
more intelligently with a wizard and so
you know these are a couple patterns
that you can use and then I want to kind
of stop there and sort of really point
out another super big misconception that
in beginning designers or people doing
yourself you know have you know they
sort of run into all the time they're
always trying to do something incredibly
novel and at the interaction design
stage I don't recommend that
I actually really recommend that you
just steal what works and so you know
don't reinvent the wheel that's very
important for you to be aware of what
are the conventions and things that
people already use and so you know these
are very basic ones for instance you
know pull-to-refresh
is something that works incredibly well
a lot of apps do it but you know it's
become a convention because it's easy
and natural to use it's satisfying it's
great to use swipe left to right you
know this was from mailbox app which
sold to Dropbox and so you know there's
a reason why you know mailbox was
incredibly innovative but the reality
was like you guys generally don't need
to and you can get really really far
with just design patterns and so you
know this does take a little bit of time
and frankly anyone who uses computers
for any amount of time you can just
click through all of these things and
you'll just you know the the you know
synapses of recognition will just kind
of come to you you'll just realize oh my
god there's actually so much that you
know you have already seen that you can
just steal wholesale and that's actually
what is desirable for you for most of
your designs you don't want to be novel
you want to be something that gets
people to the right place as quickly as
possible
and so they're just so many visa I can't
possibly cover the home like that would
be its own 10-week course so you know I
highly recommend you know go to that
website and check it out and so one of
the really interesting things I do want
to call out and you know it's sort of a
danger zone for using design patterns
you know one of the more common ones
that I've seen is actually you know
using the wrong kind of pagination like
you know one of the things that
can be very frustrating to use I've seen
you know people designed for the web and
they actually use these little dots to
represent where you are in sort of a
swiping navigation but you're on the web
and you're using a touchpad
and that makes no sense at all and in
fact it's really really bad and so you
have to be incredibly careful with
mixing modalities you know and even each
one of these design patterns as you
implement them you should sort of think
through like well why am I here what
does the user trying to do and does this
make sense for my modality here's
probably the most tactical part of the
whole talk but we're gonna start off
with a little bit of theory you know
visual design really is about you know
again these things really do blend
together it's the interaction design and
visual design are you know they're super
linked and it really is how you tell a
user what is important at the visual
level you know what emotions do we want
to evoke how do we want them to feel and
the output of this is either you know
pixel level compositions usually you
know Photoshop or you know sometimes the
actual HTML CSS and so the really
interesting thing here is that you know
to go back to function over form you
know when you're forced to be simple you
actually have to solve the real problem
so you know they want to start off by
just saying like let's just avoid as
much ornament as possible like you you
know ultimately we're here to build
something that solves people's problems
and it's about that substance when my
favorite design thinkers is actually
edward tufte he has a great book called
the visual display of quantitative
information and so one of the key
concepts that he talks about is chart
junk so he just can't stand chart junk
you know then these are just examples of
it you know here's a chart but there's
no y-axis and we don't know what the
x-axis means either and you know why
what why is that a green background and
you know for this map like why are these
these are these you know strange
gradients and what do they mean like and
then you know again what
the major misconceptions that people
starting out have around visual design
is like you know visual design is not
actually about necessarily expressing
yourself per se
the key thing is what are you trying to
what what information that you're trying
to get across and so one of the key
principles that you can actually apply
is you know just look at any design that
you're doing and just try to figure out
you know if it can be removed without
taking away any meaning so that includes
you know text that includes lines
borders you know really anything I mean
even colons like I you know the pet
peeve of mine is like seeing colons all
over a form on the web or you know in a
mobile app and it's like you know if you
removed it like would you even notice it
in fact it looks cleaner and so this is
you know a stupid example but an
incredibly basic one that you know you
can apply over and over again throughout
anything that you do you know ornaments
at the end they are not signal you're
really like then this is a very
opinionated version of design of course
but it's just work for me it's that you
know we want to eliminate this type of
ornament because we want to focus on
that which is useful and so how do we
actually do that okay so I have actually
just three very simple principles that
you can use in visual design the first
and most important is actually contrast
and so I'll just walk you through a very
simple example the most basic type of
contrast that you can give is bold
versus not bold more important less
important incredibly simple the other
that bold is not the only way you can
actually denote what is important versus
not you can use color and so that's an
incredibly valuable tool you can also
use size and so immediately you can kind
of see you know as a visual designer I
am being opinionated about what you
should pay attention to when and what is
important and what is less important and
so what's funny is if we unwind those
things all of these suddenly become
basically the same level if everything
is bold
nothing is bold and so that's something
that you should definitely remember as
you go about your business and you try
to design
anything it's you know all of you
choices around color around weight you
know it really is a question of contrast
and so it goes both to the less
important but also the more important
you know if you want to you can use
color and weight and size to also make
something even more important
the final really cool trick that I like
to use as I'm you know you you can kind
of we call it the squint test so if you
can look if you look at any webpage any
effective mobile app immediately if you
just squint your eyes at it if you can't
make out the details of what's on that
page but you can just make out the basic
shapes of you can you know without
having the ability to read any of this
you kind of know oh there's something
your eyes immediately drawn to the thing
that is the highest contrast the highest
weight on the page and so this is a very
basic you know basically your hammer for
visual design is contrast related to
that is closeness and so you know you as
a designer can take related flows
related ideas and put them together to
make them actually relate it and that
you know serves your purpose as a
designer and so I can't tell you how
often this is just a personal pet peeve
of mine you have this login page and
then why you know what is going on there
like why why is the login page it's like
it's very confusing because the user
will come here and say why is the login
there is it like a part of creating an
account it doesn't look like it's a part
of that other thing you know that to me
feel so much better and so it's a very
simple principle but you know one to be
very very mindful of but if you put all
it both just those two very simple
concepts together you get visual
hierarchy and this is where a grid
really comes into play this is why
bootstrap from Twitter was this
incredible tool that just suddenly put
in the hands of everyone here you know
the basic building blocks of being able
to create great visual design
do-it-yourself style in a nutshell you
know sort of not to break it down to the
CSS level but you could literally just
create divs that were of any size that
would automatically flow into a flexible
grid and that's incredibly valuable and
so just you know
this is just you know literally the
boilerplate stuff off of the old version
of bootstrap but you know it's a good
example of using a grid and so why this
is important well you know we can
overlay this grid and we can actually
see that we are immediately you know and
so you can see how the headings actually
just line up to particular sections of
this visual design and it's important
because users when they're using your
site they're coming to your site and
trying to figure out you know why am I
here what am I trying to do and they
will immediately be drawn to the highest
contrast things
remember the squint test you'll
immediately go ahead like headings exist
exactly for this reason a user will go
to a web page or an app and they'll
actually just scan the page and they'll
look for the highest contrast things and
try to figure out is this what I want is
what I'm looking for I have a goal is it
you know is this going to get me what I
want and then if so then they'll
actually direct their you know if if I
do care about that part then immediately
I'm going to dive deeper into you know
exactly that part and so visual hartney
is your best tool for giving your users
you know basically the guideposts like
this is the way to go so okay now we got
visual hierarchy but you know what do I
do with all of these lines and you know
why are there so many you know how do I
use color you know there's it can be
very confusing and this is a common
mistake for people who do DIY is they
just you know put boxes all over
everything or they use lines and things
like that here's my super EXTREME
oversimplification on how to do your own
layout you know basically figure out
what you need to put on the page and
then first you know try to use padding
and margin to the extent that you can
you know you can use a grid you can put
related things close to each other and
then next use a line if you have to and
so you know 90% of the time you can
probably get away with just using you
know a proper grid with enough spacing
putting related things together with
good headings thinking through the
contrast but finally you know a box is
actually a very important thing
it draws a lot of attention so that's
why you'll see it so commonly on you
know websites around a call to action it
you know really is a high contrast thing
so but be very very careful when you use
it because otherwise you know you kind
of end up with this sauce of a ton of
boxes and you know I have no idea what's
important and what I should be doing
whereas if you use the grid if you use
this sort of visual hierarchy it is very
straightforward you know the other thing
that's very valuable is like you don't
have to fill every single design you
know margin de margin white space can be
incredibly useful you know sometimes
even helping direct a user helping to
explain what's going on like having you
know space on the side just gives you a
place to put that or to just you know
focus focus the users attention and so
you know those are incredibly basic but
you know a lot of these minimal
techniques are really from you know the
folks who created Helvetica from Swiss
design in the you know mid 19th mid 20th
century you know and so there's these
are incredibly simple things but the use
of contrasts the use of a grid and the
use of color can actually do a lot okay
so I said that we're almost done with
the tactical part but I lied because
there is actually a part that I did not
cover yet most people think about design
is the creation part but it's definitely
not the only part and here's the reason
why you know if you ever put yourself
you know some of you have you took the
airport you took an airplane and walk
through SFO Airport and maybe that was
the first time you've ever been you know
every Airport is this you know itself is
designed and one of the issues with a
badly designed Airport or a badly
designed user experience is that we
don't know where to go we don't know
where we are and we don't you know the
signs are placed in the wrong place and
there's actually it's actually
incredibly hard if you put yourself in
the shoes of the the airport designer
the architect who created this Airport
and more specifically the person who put
up the you who designed where the signs
go
you know you have the design you know
where everything is you're sitting there
and you know your design tool and you
know where everything like it's all
loaded in your head but how are you
going to know for someone who's never
been that Airport you know what am I
looking at you know I'm at every given
point in that in that Airport you know
what am i trying to do what are my goals
and you know lack of proper signage is
one of the thing I'd get lost in
airports all the time I got lost in like
Paris accidentally like just like this
weekend actually and so this is actually
what feedback is designed to solve and
so there's actually two types of that
you know both designers and founders
should be really really aware of one is
usability testing so actually that
moment between the wireframe and you
know you can kind of even do this in
parallel like once you have the
wireframe you can actually start doing
usability testing with the wireframe you
can print it out and actually sit down
with people who have never seen it
before and just sort of walk them
through it or even better say you know
just ask open-ended questions you know
what are we looking at you know you can
prompt them a little bit with like oh
well you're here to do blah blah blah
and it's like what are you reading what
are you going to click next you know
what why am I here that's before you
even write a line of code you can do a
lot to test out whether or not this
thing is going to work and it's way
cheaper to do that then actually I have
to fix it in a bug in code later and
then the other part that is way way
under appreciated but is extremely
important for great product is actually
customer support most people treat their
support line is basically like kind of a
shredder you know they just don't even
look at it they don't reply to it but
the reality of product is that you know
most and this is an extremely extremely
common problem for people building
things for other people is that we
always assume that the product that
we're creating well it's just the
visible part right it's the 80% case you
know it's the ideal case in your
wireframe there in the requirement
document but the best requirement
documents the best wireframe is the best
designs the best ship thing actually
solve all of these other use cases that
you know a PM might sit there and say oh
well once in a
this happens but there are actually ten
thousand things like that that once in a
blue moon happen and if you add them all
up well you have a broken product and so
that's one of the most fundamental
reasons why we are so dissatisfied with
the products that we use day to day it's
that some p.m. or some designer looked
at that and said oh when is that ever
going to happen so the devil truly is in
these long tail bugs and you you know as
a founder of the best part it is like I
mean these big companies they they don't
think about this at all like they
literally make it impossible for you
know designers and engineers and the
product team to actually have anything
to do with customer support they just
think of their users as cattle and so
the greatest advantage that you have in
this room is that your human being you
built it yourself and when someone comes
to you and says oh my god I'm stuck here
what happened you don't have to just
throw that email in the garbage you can
say oh my god that's a bug oh I'm gonna
fix it and then once you do that you
have an evangelist for life because we
live in a world with products that are
incredibly impersonal you know we're
alone in this you know incredible place
that like you know we are so frustrated
when our products don't work and nobody
listens and so if you're the creator of
that product and you listen well you
know you only need a couple hundred
people like that and you're well on your
way to something that could be
incredibly powerful you know to steal
you know quote from Paul Buchheit don't
try and go and make something that you
know a thousand people kind of like you
really need to go and create something
that a hundred people absolutely love
and customer support is the way you can
do that and so you know and design the
designer the person who actually puts
together the wireframes who like thinks
through the user they're the best on the
whole team to actually think through
that so you know they're awesome at
advocating for the user and this process
is incredibly complicated but I just
want you to make sure that you know like
these are the parts of you know how I
think about a great product it's you
know it's not just used for research
it's all of these things one after the
other and usability testing and customer
support are the key pieces of this and
so
you know you're never done with just one
sprint you're basically in a perpetual
cycle of doing this over and over again
and you really do need to you don't need
people doing every single piece of this
but you do need to spend a little bit of
time thinking about each piece of this
you